finalmente un po di pace amore e
tranquillo non piangerà pubblici
abituerai per me sei grande maestro
nello zainetto è ovvio cena vegana e
succo di oh mi raccomando non fate
rimangiare altro sia tranquilla che mio
figlio mangia la strada quando nove mesi
corre è fermato sincronizzato sono al
pianoforte anzi se gliela devo dire
proprio tutta dovrebbe fare un altro
corso è questi bambini non sono mica
stemmi come lui ma il ma riguardi cioè
presente questi anni stanno le tabelline
è che mio figlio resta tutte preferì
empio ma poi parla anche fluentemente
l'inglese e poi sinceramente ma io posso
meyer che mio figlio sta nel corso delle
coccinelle che nome tesoro guarda due
minuti che scarico qua il tacco e arrivo
si festeggiano ma finalmente un po di
libertà in che senso dobbiamo fare
l'inserimento scusa un attimo
l'ho appena inserito a moressa inserito
bene è inserito senti adesso devo andare
perché mi inizia corso di pilates amore
mamma va a prendere una cosa in macchina
e torna subito va bene tenta dopo la
gara prendere o liga come chi sa e la
tata santa donna meno male che ce l'hai